let's go to our um
five headlines
[Music]
um this is why i've always said that the
book if you give a mouse a cookie
is one of the most prophetic works of
literature i think
in of our time in american history
certainly um
there's a great example right here the
nfl engaged in um
all kinds of racially woke pageantry
over the weekend as the nfl season
started
and we'll talk more about that in the
daily cancellation but
uh you know you thought colin kaepernick
i mean this is all being done for his
benefit
and and for the people that support him
but he was not impressed
he sent out a tweet after all of this
and he said while the nfl runs
propaganda about how much they care
about black life
they are still actively blackballing
eric reed for fighting for the black
community eric set two franchise records
last year
and is one of the best defensive players
in the league so it's one of his buddies
who doesn't have a job yet in nfl
a free agent and uh and he's upset about
that so
now first of all let me say i agree with
the first few words of what
what colin kaepernick said and that's
the most i'll ever agree with him so
we've got the first few words of that
statement in common he says the nfl is
running propaganda you're right it is
propaganda
the rest of it not so much um
but he's not satisfied and the sjws
they're never satisfied
that's why i say if you give a mouse a
cookie okay re
read that that children's books one of
my favorite books as a kid
but i didn't realize all the depth of
meaning in this book
and if you're not familiar with it and
if you give a mouse a cookie
it's all about this kid who's got a
mouse in the house and the mouse wants a
cookie
and he says okay i'll give you the
cookie but next thing you know what does
a mouse
what's a napkin and then he wants milk
and then he wants uh i don't know
carrots and then he wants every every
last thing
next thing you know he's eaten the
entire house and everything in it and
the child is left destitute
and cold on the street that's that's my
memory of the book anyway
i might be getting that slightly wrong
but the point is you get you give
you satiate with just one thing and then
it's no i need something else and
something else and something else and
something else
and that's the way it works with the
left you give them the one thing they
want
and now no now we need more and here's
the next thing here's the next thing
here's the next thing
maybe in fact instead of making my my
very intelligent literary reference here
uh maybe a better analogy would be like
the mob
okay it's it's sort of like with the mob
where you you know they they
you you you cut a deal with them you
think it's one thing and then you'll be
done
and then uh and then they come back and
they want more they don't get out of
your life at least
based on the movies that's how it seems
to go so take that
take whichever analogy you want if you
give a mouse a cookie or
a mafia movies that's as intelligent as
it gets on this show
let's go to number two the daily wire
reports it says even though the backlash
against netflix's cuties was largely
bipartisan a new op-ed in slate has put
the blame squarely on the shoulders of
conservatives according to
sam adams uh conservatives have a creepy
obsession
with the new french film which has been
accused of indefensibly sexualizing 11
year old girls in the name of artistry
uh adams wrote the movie finds itself at
the toxic
intersection of q anon delusion and
right wing moral panic with a smattering
of leftist outrage on the side
breitbart has posted about the movie a
half dozen times in the past two days
singling out critics who praised the
film several of whom have received death
threats
and have been harassed off of social
media and thursday night tucker carlson
made it a centerpiece of a show accusing
a non-specific
they behind the movie of wanting to
destroy young girls
uh then it goes on the daily wire report
adams argued that the critics of the
movie have not actually seen it
choosing instead to go off of the
marketing materials and viral clips
online addressing those who would say
that cuties pushes
softcore child pornography adams argued
that intent
matters in this case by definition
pornography requires intent and whether
or not
the director succeeded at her intent is
is uh
her unless whether or not she succeeded
her intent is clear the movie's
protagonist amy is an 11-year-old
bouncing between
the repressive culture of her
conservative islamic upbringing where
she has warned that evil
shows itself in the scantily-clad women
and the hyper-sexualized environment of
western culture where images of adult
women doing strip club gyrations are
emulated by tweens on social media
the movie presents those images in order
to critique them
uh you know even if all of that was true
the fact that it tells you everything
you need to know that this guy doesn't
even doesn't even see a problem with
that
okay so according to him the movie is
presenting
uh sort of traditional religious culture
as
equally as evil as pedophilic
uh sexualization of children for him he
sees them as both just as bad
he's putting them on the same moral
playing field so that that would be bad
enough as it is
but it's also i think uh just not true
and this idea that intent doesn't matter
in fact somebody made
an interesting point on twitter i don't
remember who it was
but made an interesting point about you
know on the left
they usually tell us intent doesn't
matter at all
so for example if somebody says the
n-word
even if they're just and it's a white
person of course white person says the n
word
even if they're just quoting someone
else
if there's there's there's no racial uh
intent at all
there's no racist intent at all even if
they're simply quoting or they're
singing along to a song where it's used
a rap song or something we're told
that intent makes no difference that's
racist even if you didn't mean it in a
race this way it is racist it's horrible
it's the worst thing that you can ever
do
that's what we're told and there are
many examples of this on the left
where usually they say intent doesn't
matter
and but they have it exactly backwards
because in most of the cases where they
say intent doesn't matter
in those kinds of cases of course intent
matters if if you're just
saying something if you're saying words
then yes when it comes to the words you
say
intent is everything i can't even begin
to be
offended by the words you say if i'm
even inclined to be offended by words in
the first place
until i know why you said them because
that's that's really
all that matters is what you meant when
you said it
now when it comes to actually
to taking actual children and putting
them in these
sexually compromised and vulnerable
positions
and sexualizing them on camera and
having them simulate sex acts through
dance on camera
and the camera's zooming in on various
body parts and everything
with something like that intent does not
matter
because the act itself
is by definition sexualization
you are by definition sexualizing a
child
the reason why you're sexually
sexualizing a child
doesn't matter i don't see that making
any moral difference whatsoever
so on one hand you have words just words
intent there is everything on the other
hand you have you
are taking actual children this isn't
like a book where they're telling a
story about this happening that would be
totally different
but these are real children who you have
taken and put them in these positions
on camera and you're profiting off of it
so the left has everything upside down
and backwards as usual
number three donald trump um said that
he is
willing to do a debate with joe biden
moderated by joe rogan
so tim kennedy tweeted out said on my
podcast with joe rogan he offered to
moderate a debate between joe biden and
donald trump it would be four hours with
no live audience
just the two candidates cameras and
their vision for how to move the country
forward
who wants this and donald trump
responded i do
now this is never going to happen but i
think it's just there really isn't any
argument
there isn't any good argument against
this i think it's very clear this would
be the best whether it's joe rogan or
somebody else
you know something like that
where it's a lengthy discussion where
the moderator is not interfering that
much
and just letting the two people have a
conversation
i guess what i'm saying is a debate
that's actually a debate can you imagine
that
that would obviously be far superior to
the to the hyper
overly moderated uh shows that we
normally get and we'll get
certainly this time if there is a debate
at all but i think that would be great
number four i mentioned earlier that blm
is one of the most morally deranged
political movements in american history
well here's more evidence if you needed
it for that claim i didn't have time to
play this during the opening but
after those two officers were shot in
los angeles a witness recorded
a video uh with his live and honest
reaction
and it is it is something watch
just aired the police out
they just aired the police
that's crazy they just got aired out
somebody ran up on the car and bust on
it
right through the window in the face and
on
it's a wrap now let's remember here this
is a woman
and a man uh both shot you know a woman
shot in the face
and lying on the ground and this guy is
he loves it leave aside the fact that
this guy apparently only knows about six
words and he just keeps repeating them
over and over again
um but he thinks it's great he's
laughing hysterically
and there are other people around too
who seem to be very impressed with this
just imagine that i really think about
it because we get so desensitized
to this sort of thing for seeing these
sorts of videos so often but
think about you somebody on the scene
sees a woman get shot in the face in
real time
and she's bleeding on the ground and
you're laughing about it
you would think even if you're a
horrible person even even
the average horrible person would at
least be so
shocked and surprised by that and
disturbed by the blood and everything
that they would probably react in a in a
relatively human way so think about how
utterly soulless you have to be to not
even have
that basic human visceral gut level
reaction to witnessing something like
that
and the point is this is the kind of
mentality and attitude
that police officers in the city
especially a city like los angeles
encounter every day i mean they're
dealing with criminals
who um i don't know if this guy's a
criminal or not certainly wouldn't
surprise me given how uh given how he
apparently feels about
given the fact that he's a big fan of
crime it seems he's very impressed with
it
but um they are dealing with with
criminals who
are just total sociopaths and
uh think that violence is funny don't
don't value human life for all the stuff
about
black lives matter yes it does all all
lives matter uh
but i think you see why um
some of the blm activists react to
all lives matter they get very upset
about that because they they really
don't think that all lives matter
the people there in that and that's a
video
they just they just don't believe they
don't see that that life matters at all
then you're a police officer and you're
coming up against this mentality every
single day
all right five finally uh joe biden was
was speaking over the weekend
uh gave a speech and this is part of the
speech that i thought was
this part here was pretty pretty
riveting watch what makes his wild
claims and hopes
he now hopes we don't notice what he
said or won't remember
and when he does follow through or
doesn't do
would follow through the exact opposite
what makes his wild claims and hopes
he now hopes we don't notice what he
said or won't remember
and when he does follow through or
doesn't do when follow through
the exact opposite that's what he just
heard there
you know biden when he speaks he has
this remarkable ability to make me
wonder
if maybe i'm the one who had the stroke
but no i'm pretty sure it was just him
i'm pretty sure he was the one
but still it does it does have this
disassociative sort of effect where you
start to question your own sanity
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated